[Music]
you ladies and gentlemen students of
Hillsdale the Friends of the college I'm
delighted to be here first time although
I have been well acquainted for a long
time with what Hillsdale means you are
men and women of Hillsdale steeped in
the best traditions of our great nation
if you don't lead by example who will
the college was founded for four things
freedom faith learning and character if
you read the 1844 document and beautiful
language that's what it says
[Music]
your education in the liberal arts has
empowered you to conserve the
foundations of our freedom and you are
now uniquely suited and I believe you
are uniquely called to renew the fabric
of our national life it will require
courage and tenacity and greatness of
spirit at times you will face opposition
but as you've learned here at Hillsdale
strength rejoices in the challenge the
term education comes from a Latin term
that means to lead for the Jacare and
fourth is the interesting part right
because you have to know which way is
fourth and fourth is a value term
there's back and there's decline and
there's decay and there's forth and
rising the source of the crisis in our
country is in education some
philosophers invented a new way of
looking at the world an innocent way
they thought we are actually not a thing
with a nature touched by the divine
instead what we are is a kind of
evolving clay and that turned education
away from what it used to be to be an
exercise to try to control influences on
us well Thomas Jefferson writes of the
laws of nature and of nature's God it is
the way of things and knowing them and
then being able to see your part in
things and that makes us responsible for
ourselves in a bigger way it takes
energy to learn it takes focus you have
to give yourself to it
[Music]
my name is Josh I'm from Pella Iowa I'm
Ryan from Temecula California my name is
Nathan I'm from Oshkosh Wisconsin my
name is Rita and I am from Nairobi Kenya
my name is failed and I'm from Holland
Michigan my name is Clara and I'm from
Cincinnati I was always planning to go
to music school coming to Hillsdale was
kind of a big shift for me I was
recruited by a lot of Division two
schools to go and play football a lot of
them felt the same but when I stepped
foot on Hillsdale I just knew it was a
different place my sister and I were
homeschooled some people always ask me
well dear friends how did you socialize
when I first decided to come to
Hillsdale my parents and I had to made
some hard choices living the country as
a 20 year old the hard thing to do and I
really respected my parents in letting
me do this and sorry I'm kind of hearing
aha when I made the decision to come to
Hillsdale I knew nothing about what the
liberal arts were it was hard for me to
at first understand how is this
practical how is this useful
everything in life is intertwined and
that's what the liberal arts experience
captures just the idea that it takes a
lot more than one discipline to make you
into a well-educated person it doesn't
just seek to develop skills in a
specific area but to develop the
character of the individual and the
ability to learn what a human being has
to do strange as it sounds the human
being has to be taught to see the world
we don't actually see reality very
clearly if we just left to our own
devices we entertain all kinds of
wishful thinking a liberal education
liberates people from all those
constraints on their understanding
reality it's a time when college-age
students are really making more choices
probably than any other time in their
life we have to help them understand how
to reach towards the good those are the
kind of people that other people follow
those are leaders
it's not very hard to take an 18 year
old and help them become an educated 21
year old adult it's a pain on everyone
involved it's also great and the point
is you orient yourself around a
combination of surveying the necessary
things and digging deeply into the best
things you gotta read philosophy and
rhetoric and logic and economics
politics and history and literature
you've got to study math chemistry
biology and physics and so that means
that you're addressing yourselves to the
great subjects that make up human
knowledge and there that's a that's an
achievement to be a person when somebody
says what do you need to know wouldn't
it be great to have an answer to that
and one can have an answer
who's got College was founded on the
frontier in 1844 and it was founded by a
bunch of Free Will Baptist preachers who
came out here on the frontier to start a
college they were very serious about
high learning and about the perpetuation
of freedom and very much founded the
skooled from its beginning to admit
people of any race both sexes so it was
pretty radical and they rubbed their
horse into town various towns and the
one who came here is a man named ransom
Dunn who worked here for 50 years
ransom Dunn wrote into Hillsdale and he
said I'd like to meet with the citizens
interested in education and that so they
met in the City Hall but it didn't have
anything to do with government
interesting point to enter at the
college you had to read Latin and Greek
and if you didn't read those things they
started a prep school where you could
just learn those things and then you
could come to college why they're gonna
read the old books the classic books the
first books written in the west of
philosophy and the the Bible with
adjustments in Greek so it's
intellectually very ambitious this is
gonna be a serious college it's gonna be
a Christian college this is gonna be a
freedom in college this college is not
gonna like slavery so much so that
during the Civil War the college halls
closed so many students up and joined
the army the college that it was kind of
a ghost college for a while you know
there were just very few students left
of course they realized that these
students are just doing exactly what we
believe is is most important and that is
defending the country defending the
unity of the country and looking to end
slavery this this terrible moral blot on
the country
the college then after the war when most
colleges and universities in the country
were taken up in the sort of heady days
of educational reform the Hillsdale
never lost sight of its founding
principles and thought we don't actually
have the Liberty to cashier our
principles and rewrite the nature and
mission the institution and then of
course in the 1950s the federal
government started funding higher
education in Hillsdale College was one
of the very few perhaps eccentric
institutions I said nope we're not going
to do it
Hillsdale College understands its
independence is essentially preserved by
not becoming a branch of the federal
government the biggest detriment of not
taking money as one doesn't have the
money the biggest benefit is it reminds
you what you're for and we focus on our
mission around here the people who
support the colors just think about that
right they don't get anything for it
they support the college because they
love the kind of thing it is
[Music]
Hillsdale College was founded as a
Christian college it remains a Christian
college of course there is some tendency
to think that a Christian college means
a college that has foreclosed important
questions and is really a kind of
indoctrination institution quite the
reverse
it opens the education up to the
ultimate point at which everything comes
to be fully meaningful and integrated
you can't have a liberal arts education
without God because you would have to do
without the idea of the perfect and sure
enough by logic that would deprive you
of understanding why anything is higher
than anything else and so come to find
out the idea of God is the motive toward
which all learning moves our College
motto is strength rejoices in the
challenge and what does that mean it
means it's a rigorous undertaking to try
to know the best things and live
according to them some people smile
about our motto that strength rejoices
in the challenge but it's so true life
is a challenge and if they don't go
through challenging times here they're
not gonna be prepared for life the value
that was instilled to me the most by my
family was the hard work ethic I grew up
in a Christian family strong in faith
and tongue as people my parents
instilled in me a very strong work ethic
they taught me anything is possible
you're willing to go get it strength of
choices and the challenge is in many
ways a battle cry for Hillsdale there
are a lot of times when the motto
strengths or choices in the challenge
confuse me because I'm definitely not
feeling strong freshmen and sophomore
year maybe I did not rejoice in the
challenge quite as much as I have the
last couple of years I'm feeling like
there are three papers to do several
books to read and I don't know how I'm
going to get it all done as someone
preparing himself to be a Marine officer
this war cry of strength of choices and
the challenge is so important who places
that are the most uncomfortable or
sometimes the best places to be because
of how they challenge and grow you
there is just an accomplishment that you
feel that you don't feel when things
aren't as hard just coming from a place
that trains you to embrace these
challenges it's a skill that you use
every single day of your life whether it
be in the academic circle where I didn't
quite get the grade I wanted on a paper
or whether it be in sports where I
thought I would come in and you know be
a starter one day but I've seen myself
more in a backup role you can see those
things as you know failures or you can
see them as opportunities to get better
you're not gonna get strong in a day but
eventually if you keep working at it
you're gonna reach your goal it requires
to embrace the challenges to embrace the
suck as the Marine Corps would say pilla
college is a very demanding place
there are numerous amount of challenges
that we face and the hardest probably
being the balancing of a lot of good
things through that process you fail a
lot but you learn through that failure
the purpose of strength or joyce's in
the challenge is to build you into a
better person by the time you leave
you